-Our first guest tonight
hosts the Emmy-
and Peabody Award-winning show
"Last Week Tonight,"
which airs Sunday nights on HBO
and streams on HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend
John Oliver, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-Good, thank you.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
No, no.
-You love this stuff.
-I d--
-You love applause
and attention.
-I don't like it.
I don't like it.
[ Cheering ]
I was this close to leaving.
Half is a bit.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel very lucky
to see you here.
I saw you last week
at the Emmys.
Congratulations on your victory.
-Thanks very much.
-Also, congratulations --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like you had --
The award was presented to you
by Selena Gomez,
Martin Short, and Steve Martin.
-Yes.
-That's a very nice trio
to get it from.
-Definitely, yeah.
I kind of -- when they came out,
they'd said,
"Our award is next,"
and it did seem like
this must be a mistake.
They're not gonna slum it in
"Best Variety Show," are they?
And then they did.
Yeah, it was amazing.
My wife's favorite movie
is "Clifford."
-Yeah.
-So to get an award
from Clifford is about as happy
as she's been with me
for five years.
-Based on the reaction
to you saying that,
I think it might only
be her favorite movie.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I --
that's a Martin Short film
where Martin Short
plays a child named Clifford.
-Yeah, it's really good.
It's really good.
-It's really good.
-And even though we're both
selling it really hard,
you can feel an innate sense of,
"I don't think --"
[ Laughter ]
There's no curiosity of,
"I'll watch that tonight."
It's just, "Nope, this is
another thing that I will miss."
-Just do us a favor.
It's not a giant commitment.
Watch the trailer
on YouTube of "Clifford"...
-Yeah.
-...starring Martin Short.
-And then, when you get to
the end of it and think,
"Not for me," remember,
it is really good.
-Yep.
-To be honest,
I've just come here to sell
"Clifford."
[ Laughter ]
I just don't think --
-This is a new thing.
You're plugging old films.
-Yes, that's right.
I just don't think enough people
have seen "Clifford."
So, do we have a clip?
[ Laughter ]
-You got to tell us ahead
of time if you want a clip.
I'm so sorry.
-Oh, that's how it works?
I thought you could just say,
"Do you have a clip?",
and they'd google it quick.
[ Laughter ]
-Give them time.
Maybe by the end.
-Yeah, sure.
-So what about --
Do you enjoy being at the Emmys?
-No.
-Yeah.
-Not at all, no.
[ Laughter ]
No, it would've been nicer
to see you
literally anywhere else
on Earth.
But, you know, it's what
America does best, in a way.
It's pageantry.
-Yeah.
-It's like a royal funeral
without a dead queen.
-Okay. Well...
[ Laughter ]
You know what I like about you?
You know what I like
the most about you?
You bring your own segues.
Now, John...
[ Laughter ]
The last time you were here
was a couple days
after Prince Philip
had passed away.
-That's right, yes.
-And now, obviously you're here
on the day
of the Queen's funeral.
-I am, yeah.
-And you're sort of our royal
correspondent by fate
more than anything else.
-That's right, that's right.
[ Laughter ]
-How are you taking it all in?
-Thanks, thanks.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's a difficult day.
Craig, you're from
the U.K., right?
-I am, yeah.
-Sorry for our loss.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I didn't know her.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
You guys promised me
Craig knew her.
-Yeah, you know, basically,
whenever a senior royal dies,
I will come here.
[ Laughter ]
Just click your heels
three times, and I will be here
to give it
the disrespect it deserves.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, thank you very much.
-It's been a very weird time
in Britain.
This 10 days in forced mourning,
apparently,
has been very, very strange.
-Yes.
And one of the --
We were talking about this
at the Emmys,
'cause we're both football fans.
-Yes.
-I should clarify --
we're talking about soccer.
Which was --
they did not play any
of those games for about a week.
-They didn't.
They kept -- rugby and cricket
was allowed to go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
And football had to stop
in an act of, I think,
tangible class warfare.
[ Laughter ]
-Because of the fan bases
of those three sports?
-I mean, it's hard to --
They will say
it was for other reasons,
but I think
it was probably that.
-Yeah.
-I think they were concerned
about how football fans
would respond
to a minute's silence
and maybe they would not
be able to go the whole minute.
[ Laughter ]
But it's the interesting thing.
It's always -- the question
in their mind is always,
"Well, will they behave?",
not "Why might they not?"
[ Laughter ]
There's no introspection
or follow-up
for, "Why might they decide
to editorialize that?"
-Yeah, and then,
there's also the likelihood
of maybe a chant or two.
Or a song that could happen.
-That's right.
We do love a song, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's been
a very weird 10 days.
I think -- they had in
Morrison's, the supermarket --
#Ad.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm here -- I'm here to promote
"Clifford" the movie
and a low-grade
British supermarket.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, they lowered
the sound of the beeps
at the checkout
out of respect
for the queen dying.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, she did --
She hated beeps.
-She hated beeps.
[ Laughter ]
As if someone would've gone in,
heard the regular beep,
and said,
"Have some [bleep] respect!"
[ Laughter ]
"She's lying in state!"
"As is tradition,
a quieter beep is appropriate!"
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe there was a way
to have the beep be quieter
this whole time.
-Well, at first,
I thought that cannot be true.
They can mute the beeps.
They choose not to.
-Yeah.
-Again, that's the crime here.
-That's right.
And after Charles becomes king,
the beeps will return.
[ Laughter ]
-Double, twice as loud.
-Unnecessarily loud volume,
yeah.
It's been a stupid time.
-You were offered
the order of the British Empire,
the O.B.E., I guess.
-I was, yes.
-And that must be a very
interesting call to receive.
-It is.
It is a call.
They called up, and they --
This is before I got
my citizenship here in America.
And so, you know,
as an immigrant on a visa
or green card,
your immigration status
is a perpetual anxiety for you.
They left a message saying
that you need to call
the British consulate
immediately,
which doesn't sound like --
Unless you're Jason Bourne,
and...
[ Laughter ]
...physically and emotionally,
I just am not.
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was something
really bad.
And then, this guy picks up
the phone and says,
"I'm here with a letter
from the Queen in front of me."
It was so offensively English,
his accent.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think you're allowed
to do this accent.
Yeah, and he said,
"I'm here to say
that you're on the New Year's
honors list,"
and I knew what was coming.
"I don't think I want this."
He went, "Don't answer now."
And I said, "I just did."
[ Laughter ]
I said --
I said, "I don't want it."
And so he said,
"I'll call back tomorrow."
And he did. I said, "Yeah,
my answer hasn't changed.
I really don't want this."
[ Laughter ]
It's a loaded --
O.B.E....
-Yeah.
-...is a loa--
The "B.E." part of that
is a hell of a thing
to want after your surname.
Yeah, so I didn't.
And he said,
"Please don't tell anyone,"
and I said,
"I am telling everybody I know."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is --
Let's just be clear.
I have made no pr--
If I'm making a promise,
I'm breaking it instantly.
The moment this phone goes down,
I'm calling people.
-I bet -- obviously,
based on his reaction,
it probably doesn't happen often
that people turn him down.
-I think -- I think it probably
happens all the time.
I just think it's not then
people that just say,
"I have to tell people that this
was a very funny conversation."
-You had --
-My wife was mad, though,
'cause she wanted to go
to Buckingham Palace.
I had to kind of explain to her,
"Listen, there's a class system
in England.
This is stuff -- it's not
important for you to know this,
but I really can't go there
and behave."
[ Laughter ]
-You did have a joke
censored by --
-Yes!
-I guess your show airs
on Sky over there.
-Yes.
Yeah, they, uh --
-Not really a censorable joke.
-It was -- I don't --
It wasn't really --
It barely had the properties
of a --
All we said was
that Britain is still mourning
the shocking loss -- right? --
of a 96-year-old woman
from natural causes.
[ Laughter ]
It's not -- it's not --
literally not a joke.
Scientifically,
that's not a joke.
That's just a fact with a kind
of dickish inflection.
That's all it is.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, they cut it out.
-Wow.
-Which is pretty [bleep]
because apparently
all we've heard all week
is the Queen
had an incredible
sense of humor.
[ Laughter ]
Just non-stop,
"Oh, she was so funny."
Seth, she was so funny.
The Queen, she was razor sharp.
[ Laughter ]
She dreamt of going
to the Del Close Marathon.
Big comedy fan.
-I will say,
I've watched a lot of anecdotes
of people saying,
"She was so funny,"
and then they tell a story,
and when it ends, you go,
"I don't know."
-Yeah, or that clip.
Or that clip.
It's like -- And there she was
with Paddington.
I'm watching a bear carry her
comedically in that scene.
[ Laughter ]
She's giving that bear
nothing back.
There is one set of footprints
in the sand, and it's a paw.
[ Laughter ]
But she was a huge comedy fan.
-Huge comedy fan.
And liked the good --
yeah, "The State."
She loved "The State."
[ Laughter ]
-She just wanted to live to see
Mulaney's tour.
That was the thing
that she didn't --
[ Laughter ]
Why is that the thing?!
Ask yourself
why that was your line.
-Yeah, and then let us know.
[ Laughter ]
John Oliver, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Last Week Tonight"
airs Sunday nights on HBO
and streams on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with Quinta Brunson.